so good afternoon everyone yes my name
is Anthony lizards and I am the director
of strategic initiatives and the Yale
project on climate change here at the
School of Forestry okay so I'd like to
begin by just saying thank you for all
all of you to come for coming today to
the third lecture of our visions of the
sustainable world lecture series we're
very very pleased to welcome dr. Robert
Costanza a co-founder of the field of
ecological economics to share his vision
of how we all can flourish on a bio
physically limited planet now by way of
background this project emerged from a
conference that we organized back in
2007 that tried to identify the
underlying values and worldviews that
are going to be required to become
sustainable in the 21st century among
its many conclusions this group
recognized that there is currently a
critical lack of inspiring yet practical
visions of the sustainable world and
roadmaps to get us there for decades
society has had to react to a seemingly
endless series of environmental crises
oil spills pollution toxics
deforestation and dangerous species and
now of course global environmental
challenges but in responding to these
many threats the environment community
has unfortunately often been much better
at articulating what it is against
deforestation climate change etc then
articulating what it's for thus
environmental research and action has
often not been strategic in pursuit of a
visionary goal instead of ideals and in
this context our lecture series hopes to
help catalyze concrete visions of the
economy's political systems environments
values and lifestyles of a sustainable
world that in fact does lie within our
reach our first speaker was dr. Paul
Raskin a director of the great
transition initiative who presented a
provocative history from the future
tracing how a sustainable planetary
civilization in the year twenty eighty
four was achieved
we then hosted Alex Stephan co-founder
of world-changing org who spoke about
building a bright green future that
works and showcased inspiring examples
of the sustainable world being
constructed right now by individuals and
communities around the world videos of
the full lectures and short in-depth
interviews with all of our speakers are
available through the Yale YouTube
channel or the project website and I
encourage you to visit environment
yale.edu forward slash visions I'd now
like to take a moment to thank first of
all the Geraldine R dodge foundation for
their support of this lecture series and
David grant their soon-to-be outgoing
president who's here in the audience
today thank you David so much for your
support also thanks to the Yale Center
for Business and Environment at Yale and
the Yale office of sustainability for
their support of today's lecture and
their everyday efforts to make
sustainability a reality right here
right now in New Haven so it's now my
pleasure to turn it over to our Dean's
or Peter crane who will introduce
today's speaker thank you well by now
you'll be anxious to get to the main to
the main course it's my simple pleasure
to introduce dr. Robert Costanza the
Gordon and luli Gunn professor of
ecological economics and director of the
gun the Institute for ecological anomaly
economics at the University of Vermont
Bob Costanza received his BA and MA
degrees in architecture and
environmental engineering sciences all
from the University of Florida he's the
author or co-author of more than 400
scientific papers and 20 books including
the landmark paper published in Nature
in 1997 the value of the world's
ecosystem services a natural capital
which is one of the most highly cited in
fact the second most highly cited
article in ecology and environment of
the last decade that article has
received a huge response it really was
an important moment in the development
of the field of E coli ecological
economics in which bob has played an
absolutely foundational role we're very
pleased and privileged to have him here
today and please join me in welcoming
him
- here in our school
good it's a real pleasure to be here and
I noticed this quirk of human psychology
that the first two rows of any lecture
hall are never never filled up so I'm
glad that that's not any different but
otherwise I think this is a fantastic
facility that you have thanks to to Gus
Speth and all of his his efforts so
flourishing on a bio physically limited
planet lessons from ecological economics
I want to first point out as you as
probably all of you now realize that
we're we are in a completely different
time Paul Crutzen is called our current
geologic era the Anthropocene so we're
not even in the whole Essene any longer
we're we're in an era when human impacts
on the life-support system are so large
that we're in a completely different
geologic era a place we've never been
before and if you can see this very well
but it's the night time satellite
imagery pasted it on this rotating globe
it's also true that to really solve some
of the many problems that we're that
we're facing now requires that we
integrate these three elements of having
an adequate vision not only of how the
world works but also of how we would
like the world to be and I'll touch on
both of these elements of vision as I as
I go through the talk and our tools and
analytical techniques have to be then
appropriate to this this changing vision
as do our our implementation strategies
our institutions our technologies all of
those things need to change I think as a
as a unit as a as a regime so how do we
make a regime shift if you will into
this new sustainable and desirable
future I think the the mainstream is is
is even catching on to some of these
ideas this is from a editorial by Thomas
Friedman recently in the New York Times
asking that you know what if this
recession that we're in now represents
more than just another recession what if
it's really telling us that this whole
growth model that we've been building
over the last 50 years is just
economically and ecologically
unsustainable and that we've really hit
hit the wall so I think our challenge is
really what do we do next just a little
background I'm sure many of you are
aware of many of these issues a lot of
that that growth in our in our economic
system has been driven by the
consumption of fossil fuels particularly
oil and gas which is scheduled to peak
if it hasn't already and and decline in
the future probably at a faster rate
even than then is shown there because of
the fact that the net energy from these
oil and gas liquids will decline even
even faster of course we still have a
lot of of coal coal is not due to peak
until until much later but but oil runs
much of our economy and changes in oil
supply certainly have have dramatic
effects as do the geographic
distribution of our remaining oil stocks
this shows in red the ultimate
recoverable oil stocks and in black the
remaining oil stocks distributed around
the planet and you can see that all of
the big black circles are really in very
problematic geographic areas at the same
time we are learning much more and
quickly about how our life-support
system functions at multiple scales due
to the enormous efforts that we put into
synthesizing much of this information
this is a global climate model run from
the National Center for Atmospheric
Research showing in white
relative humidity and an orange
precipitation and I think it's a
compelling visual image if nothing else
that gives you a picture in one in one
place of how this complex climate system
that we're now impacting is functioning
and and also gives us the tools to start
to begin to understand how changing
things like the carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere would
affect the functioning of this of this
atmospheric system I'm sure you've all
seen this diagram the famous hockey
stick diagram showing the historical
reconstructions of temperature in the
northern hemisphere the the temperature
increases in the historical period in
red and the projections of the various
climate models like the one I was just
showing into the future under different
scenarios all of which show increases of
two
to six degrees centigrade or so you've
probably also seen the stern review on
the economics of climate change and this
graph just indicates some of the impacts
of changes in temperature on the various
elements of the system on food water
ecosystems extreme weather events abrupt
and major irreversible changes the CERN
review concluded in summary that keeping
the temperature increases below two
degrees centigrade which would minimize
many of the damages would cost and from
a very conventional economic point of
view would cost on the order of 1 maybe
2 percent of global GDP but not
addressing those impacts and allowing
them to occur would cost on the order of
5 to 20 percent of global GDP so the
bottom line is is that prevention is
certainly much less expensive than
curing the problem after its occurred as
as we know from many other examples it's
also I think important to to recognize
and to and to bring into our
consideration a much longer historical
perspective if we wish to understand
sustainability I think we need to
understand how historical societies have
have either sustained themselves or not
or have collapsed in the past and I
think we need to build a more integrated
science of the past in order to help us
build this this this more sustainable
and desirable future all of this goes to
the unbuilding a better vision of how
the how the world works how it has
worked in the past how it does work now
from this complex systems point of view
and as a basis for building a better
future one project I'm involved with is
called I hope the integrated history and
future of people on earth and the idea
here is to do just that to bring
together a broad interdisciplinary group
to integrate what we know about
environmental history the emerging data
that we're collecting on the Earth's
environment in the past and and human
history this graph tries to show that in
one on one page it's kind of a it's a
log plot with going starting here at 10
thousand I'm sorry a hundred thousand
years ago ten thousand one thousand one
hundred and so on so on and showing on
the right technological changes on the
left various civilizations that have
come and gone I'll just point out a
couple of features of this that the the
red line there is the average
temperature in the Northern Hemisphere
and you can see that during the
Pleistocene when the human species
evolved the the temperature was quite
erratic and going from ice ages to
interglacial periods quite quite often
it wasn't till the beginning of the
Holocene at around ten thousand years
ago that that the temperature stabilized
at a fairly high and fairly moist level
and that our entire civilization really
has been built during that period since
the beginning of the Holocene when the
climate was relatively stable you can
see that we're starting to push that
temperature record off off to the right
a bit as we get to the the recent past
also point out one one other thing this
called the start of the the great
acceleration here as it's been named
since the end of World War two you can
see there are sort of kinks and many of
these curves where things have taken off
even faster than exponentially largely
as the result of the consumption of the
oil and gas liquids that we were talking
about before you've probably also seen
Jared Diamond's book on collapse again I
think the contribution of this is really
to start to build this more scientific
understanding of the past how do we
integrate all of the pieces that we know
about what's happened he pointed out
twelve of the most serious problems that
face these historical societies and all
of these will look very familiar to you
today because I think our society is
facing all of them at the same time and
our society unlike the historical
societies that have collapsed is really
a global society if it's it's so
interconnected that if one piece of it
collapses it's going to radically affect
the rest of the system and I think the
issue is really this issue of resilience
had we had
we lost resilience in the system and we
created a system it's so brittle that
it's it's prone to collapse we've
certainly had other magnifying problems
due to the the increases in temperature
so far increasing frequency and
intensity of storms increasing number of
flood events globally approaching
rapidly approaching global tipping
points in the climate system this from
Tim Linton at all recently identifying
several of the potential tipping points
in the climate system where relatively
small changes can lead to relatively
large changes in the in the overall
climate system the ice sheets melting is
probably the most well known one but
there are several others that we need to
take into consideration based on all of
this a group of us I was I was one of
among I guess I haven't counted them
lately but they're I think somewhere
around 28 co-authors on this paper tried
to identify the the boundaries for a
safe operating space for Humanity within
the biophysical limits of the of the
planet we identified nine different
boundaries that are that are shown here
in this diagram the green circle in the
middle is where we place the the safe
operating space and you can see that
climate change is one of those that that
we have already passed the boundary we
agreed with with Jim Hansen that 350
parts per million boundary represented a
safe operating space again we're
considering that many of these variables
have tipping points and rapid changes
that could be occurring and that the
safe operating space was defined as
being before we get to the point where
those things start to change very
quickly
so it's not that there's no going back
but we don't know how far we can exceed
those boundaries before we run into
serious problems you can see that the
other major boundaries that have been
already exceeded are the biodiversity
loss boundary and exceeded by quite a
bit and the the nitrogen cycle boundary
we're now putting so much more nitrogen
into the system and then it had
historically been used to having
having major impacts already several of
the other boundaries are still within
the safe operating space and and some a
couple we we really failed to to
quantify yet anyway
and we put this out I think very much as
a as a challenge to the the scientific
community to begin to think about where
these these boundaries should be and
also to think about institutionally how
we could create the the institutions to
keep humanity within the safe operating
boundaries but also for it to flourish
and and be prosperous so one question I
think that comes up immediately from all
of this is that in this new context that
we're facing not I hope I've convinced
you not any longer in an empty world but
we're in a full world context and what
is the economy and what is it for in
this in this context the conventional
view has has been that you know the
economy is the market and the the
purpose of the economy is to maximize
the rate of production and consumption
in the market but I think if we go back
a little further in economic thinking
the the purpose of the economy is really
to sustain human wellbeing and so I
think we need to take that seriously and
to really change our vision of the goals
of this of the economy and of our
society to to one of sustaining creating
and sustaining a desirable future if you
if you take that definition then the
economy becomes something much broader
than simply the market because the
market contributes to to well-being but
it certainly is not the only contributor
it's a means to an end it is not the end
in itself there are many other factors
like the contributions of natural and
social capital that are outside the
market that contributes significantly to
well-being and that need to be brought
in if our goal really is to create the
sustainable and desirable future just to
highlight the conventional view a little
bit further the conventional view of the
economy is this simple perpetual motion
machine of firms and households cycling
goods and services and factors of
production back and forth between them
it ignores all of the contributions of
natural inputs and environmental
services it ignores the sinc functions
of the the atmosphere for example it
ignores many of the biophysical cycles
that we've just been talking about it
ignores the fact that we live on a
finite planet driven by mainly by solar
energy so our vision of how the world
works I think needs to be much more
cognizant of this broader view of what
the economy is and what it's for to
highlight that maybe a little bit more
this is a the empty world model of the
economy in a slightly different form
with the three primary factors of
production land labor and capital but
you can see that land is kind of grayed
out here because there's the assumption
of almost perfect substitutability
between these factors so if we ran out
of land natural resources forests all of
the things that you guys are studying
not a problem
we can just substitute more manufactured
capital or labor produce more goods and
services measured by GDP and then those
are either consumed or reinvested to
produce more capital in the next period
so we can produce and consume more in
the future there's nothing in this
vision of the economy that in any way
limits the growth of the economy into
the indefinite future it also assumes
that the more we produce and consume the
better better off we are so the bit the
basic premises are more is always better
this economy can grow forever scale then
is not a problem the scale of the
economy within the biosphere is not a
problem if it were a problem we could
solve it technologically poverty can
best be solved with more growth there's
the idea that a rising tide lifts all
boats that nature is really a sideshow
in this model you know we can maybe if
we can afford you know the environment
that's that's fine if we can't no big
deal and private property is always best
because we're talking about rival and
excludable marketed goods and services
largely now some people I think take
this literally into extremes this is uh
this is an in-flight magazine ad that I
found I didn't make this up this isn't
that photoshopped at all and this is
from Alabama power their motto is always
on so they want Alabama at
the state of Alabama there if you didn't
recognize it from space to look like
that with all the lights on all the time
of course others are taking a more
adaption astir proach to this the
climate problem and this is there's an
actual ad from diesel clothing and this
is their global warming ready line of
clothes so you know it's okay as long as
you hit as long as you dress properly
you know
the apocalypse is not a problem I don't
think that's the way we want to go but I
think we do need to change our vision of
what what the economy is what it's for
what our goals are and be more cognizant
of the way the world really works and
that's this full world model of the of
the ecological economic system tries to
make some of those points recognizing
first of all that we do live in this
materially closed Earth System that
these four types of capital including
conventional manufactured capital but
also human capital social capital
natural capital are not infinitely
substitutable for each other they are
all required in some appropriate balance
in order to run even the conventional
economic production but also they
produce goods and services that affect
human wellbeing directly without going
through the market so it recognizes that
human wellbeing is a much more complex
function than simply the more we consume
the better off we are and the
psychological evidence is rapidly
building to demonstrate that there's a
whole new science of happiness if you
will or a positive psychology that that
recognizes that that well-being is
affected by material consumption only up
to a fairly low threshold and then it's
well it flattens out and other things
really contribute to well-being beyond
that including these the contributions
of natural and social capital so anyway
I think the global recession that we're
still in represents a an opportunity to
change to change tracks to change our
worldviews our institutions our
technologies in a more integrated way to
get on to a track that leads to a more
sustainable and desirable future I think
a key element in allow
us to do that is to create this vision
of what a sustainable and desirable
future would look like a vision that's
communicable enough to a broad enough
audience to make the point that it is
not a sacrifice to make this transition
really it's a sacrifice not to make the
transition but I don't think that choice
has really been adequately put before
the public I don't think the public has
really been adequately involved in in
creating that that vision so I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a second
but first a couple of other points about
the the way the world works the
psychology of well-being I think is an
important new sight in scientific
direction recognizing that quality of
life has at least these three elements
of there's a sense of subjective
well-being that people feel and there's
been a lot of work surveying individuals
actually scanning their brains as well
to see you know when when they're happy
how they feel happy and what they feel
happy about and making the connections
between that and the basic human needs
that are fulfilled in order to feel that
sense of of well-being and those needs
transcend simple subsistence and
consumption and material material goods
but include many of the other things on
this list as you'll all probably
recognize from a little bit of
introspection that leisure and
creativity and freedom and identity and
understanding and affection are all
extremely important to people in terms
of basic needs for for having a high
quality of life and yet our economic
policies largely ignore many of those
things ignore the whole issue of what
really contributes to quality of life
and focus on material consumption we can
create the opportunities for people to
meet their needs and to feel the sense
of subjective well-being by arranging
our assets more appropriately our built
our human and also our social and our
natural capital assets and how we use
our time so I think that's our real
challenge from a policy performing that
point of view is how do we how do we
integrate our understanding of what
leads to a high quality of life with how
we manage our
our assets this graph which you may have
seen before in various forms just shows
the relationship between GNP per capita
and life satisfaction on the on the
y-axis based on surveys of people around
the world and it shows that there is
certainly a strong relationship between
consumption and well-being at the lower
end of the curve but at the upper end of
the curve it pretty much flattens out
and and the USA way over here is not
really any happier than then New Zealand
or Ireland or Portugal way back here in
the consumption consumption pattern so
what above around 10000 or so dollars
per capita GDP life satisfaction doesn't
really improve much with additional
consumption so what we really should be
aiming for
from a policy perspective if our goal
again is shifted away from more
consumption is better and towards
quality of life and spreading around
that quality of life as much as we can
we should maybe be aiming for this this
the circle here at the break point where
the over developed countries could could
deal with a little less consumption and
the underdeveloped countries need a
little bit more consumption how we
measure well-being is is also
problematic and a lot of our policy
decisions are made these days on
maximizing GDP GDP is a very poor
measure of economic well-being in fact
it was never designed to measure
economic welfare it was only designed to
measure economic activity or or income
and only the marketed part of that
economic income so if there's an oil
spill somebody has to go clean it up
that leads to more activity that's more
GDP if there's more crime if there's
more pestilence if there's more
disasters of various kinds
GDP goes up but many of the things we
count in GDP are actually costs and not
benefits we haven't really separated
them well so there have been some
efforts to do just that to separate the
benefits from the costs and this index
of sustainable economic welfare for
example or the genuine progress
indicator is one but we could take that
a little further and say what we really
need to be measuring is how well human
needs are
actually being met and an efficient
economy the goal for the economy would
be to meet those needs with as little
consumption with as little GDP as
possible rather than equating GDP with
well-being the GPI or icw has these
elements it can sit starts with personal
consumption expenditures which are a
major component of GDP but then it
weights those by income distribution to
recognize that $1 worth of income to a
rich person doesn't produce as much
welfare as $1 worth of income to a poor
person because of that diminishing
return kind of relationship it adds some
things that are left out of GDP the
value of household labour and volunteer
work and then it subtracts a whole bunch
of things that are in GDP but shouldn't
be like the costs of crime and family
breakdown and and all these green
elements are losses of natural capital
costs of water and air pollution and
noise pollution etc not the perfect
indicator by any means of well-being but
but certainly an interesting one and a
better approximation I would argue than
GDP for economic well-being it's been
applied in several different countries
around the world who can see some of the
results here and often the relationship
turns into something like what has
happened in the US will we're from 1950
to about 1975 these two were highly
correlated during that period built
capital infrastructure was really the
limiting factor after after World War
two so GDP was what was required
increasing GDP what was really required
to improve well-being improved
well-being but since then the costs of
that additional growth have began to
outweigh or at least balance out the
benefits and since then since 1975 you
could argue we've been in a recession of
quality of life so you know the GDP
recession is I think not as important as
the quality of life recession that we've
been in for for quite a while longer
than that again this gets back to what
is our vision what are the goals that
we're pursuing if our goals are to
maximize GDP we've been doing fine if
our goals are really to create a
sustainable and desirable world and we
haven't been doing so well and I would
argue we need to switch from the former
to the latter of course some places have
been doing bed
than others along these lines this is a
study that we did in Vermont showing
that in in the state of Vermont
Chittenden County in Burlington GPI has
continued to increase even though the US
average has has leveled off largely
because of I think the greater attention
in Vermont to natural and social capital
kinds of issues you may know also that
the state of Maryland has recently
become the first state the first
official government entity that I know
of
that's going to start routinely
collecting and publishing the this
genuine progress indicator results as a
way of keeping track of something
broader than GDP is their their measure
of progress so I think that's a
significant development these data are
also pretty consistent with surveys of
life satisfaction in the US which have
remained fairly constant since the since
the mid 1970s so we've we've doubled GDP
over this period and yet our happiness
hasn't really improved at all so the
bottom line I think in all of this is
that growth and material consumption is
is not sustainable from a biophysical
point of view and it also doesn't
necessarily bring happiness it's not
really desirable so what is this new
vision that we need and what are the
elements of the new vision and how do we
how do we actually achieve it I would
argue that we need to to build this
vision together as a society I'll get a
little bit more into that but but before
I do maybe I'll just point out a few of
the other elements I think one element
is recognizing that the Commons as as
Peter Barnes has defined them here as
all the gifts that we inherit or create
together our significant contributors to
our to our well-being that they are not
simply minor externalities things that
we can't afford to ignore but we have to
bring them very much to the forefront
and he's argued that we need a new
operating system for capitalism version
3.0 as opposed to version 2.0 before
that the system crashes so our natural
and social capital assets are really
what we're talking about here as as the
Commons we've estimated
or it's been estimated that the value of
those common assets far exceeds the
value of our private and state assets in
the United States so these are not minor
elements but these are if you if you
will the majority of our economic
well-being is coming from things that
are that are outside the market not
inside the market ecosystem services
certainly contribute a huge part of that
and the paper that the Dean mentioned in
1997 we tried to identify these 17
different ecosystem services and
quantify the degree to which they
contribute to human wellbeing you can
see that they range from very global
level things like climate regulation to
more regional things like water supply
nutrient cycling waste treatment many of
the things that we can't do without in
order to survive but that have now
become limiting factors that have now
become the things that we need to
economize on we estimated their total
value at 16 to 54 trillion dollars per
year altogether significantly larger
than global GDP but almost certainly an
underestimate of the the value of all of
these resources because of the many
problems that we identified with with
doing this exercise but again
recognizing that solving any of these
problems except maybe number six would
lead to an even larger number and I
think that's been verified the
Millennium ecosystem assessment which
you've probably heard about is a more
recent compendium of 1,300 scientists
working together to try and identify the
status and trends of ecosystem services
around the world the benefits that
people derive from functioning
ecosystems and I think this this idea
does change the whole vision and and the
nature of the debate around around the
environment but it's not you can't look
at it as the environment versus the
economy if the environment is providing
a whole range of services that that are
extremely valuable and then are as as or
more valuable than our conventional
economic assets so it's really changes
it to one of let's look at our assets
more comprehensively this idea has been
taken up quite actively fairly recently
by a number of
of federal and state agencies the the US
EPA has now started a an office of
ecosystem services research there's a
study underway funded by the UN and
Deutsche Bank called teeb the economics
of ecosystems and biodiversity and
several other initiatives just showing
the the rapid increase in this the
activity around this area the state of
New Jersey recently commissioned a study
that we did on assessing the value of
their ecosystem services and natural
capital I think several other government
agencies at other levels are also
becoming interested in that it's also
clear that that converting our remaining
natural assets to other uses has
significant economic downsides if you
consider the economy more broadly in the
way that I'm talking about this is from
the Millennium assessment again showing
the loss of value in converting intact
wetlands to intensive farming
sustainable forestry into small-scale
farming etc if one considers the total
value of all of the ecosystem services
on the top end we did a study recently
to try to assess excuse me the benefit
cost ratio of preserving our global
natural capital assets and we started
with a scenario of increasing the global
reserve network to 15 percent of the of
the terrestrial biosphere 30 percent of
the marine biosphere that would cost we
estimated around forty five billion
dollars per year but the benefits the
net difference between the intact system
and the converted system would be on the
order of four to five trillion dollars a
year so a benefit cost ratio of a
hundred to one quite a good investment
these days the only better investment I
could find was for oil companies
investing in political campaigns
unfortunately hopefully that's changed
so now I want to move on more to the
topic I think of this talk of the
importance of envisioning and what a
future vision of our nation of our of
our cities of our entire world would
look like and how do we create that
vision and how do we communicate it this
is from a paper that Dana Meadows
published in 1996 on principles for
effective envisioning and I think that
is our our challenge these days our most
important challenge how do we create a
shared vision and and and implement it
so her principles are these these five
that we have to focus on what we really
want and not what we'll settle for and I
can see on the left there's a list of
things we really want we want human
happiness we want permanent prosperity
we don't really want GDP or
unsustainable growth which is what we've
been getting
the vision should be judged by the
clarity of its goals not the clarity of
its implementation path so often we get
we get stuck by saying well this could
never happen so therefore we won't put
it on the table you have to put that
aside and say what is it that we really
want and then the path will reveal
itself number three is that responsible
vision much must acknowledge but not get
crushed by the physical and political
constraints of the real world another
version of the same thing we can't we
can't let the seeming impossibility of
these things get in the way of putting
forth division because the vision can be
extremely empowering and can and can
allow people to do things that they
would never have thought they could do
before number four it's critical to be
for the visions to be shared I think
this is one that we often ignore and how
do we do that I think that should be
really the essence of a democratic
society is this process of creating a
shared vision as an ongoing process it's
not something that we do in 1776 you
know among a relatively small group and
write it down and then that's the end of
it you know that's something that we
need to do every day is to continually
talk about discuss
share and create this this vision of the
of what a sustainable and desirable
future would be so I think that's a big
part of our challenge on the political
side how do we how do we create the
institutions to allow us to really do
that and and the the fifth point I think
goes to what I was just saying the
vision has to be flexible and evolving
so it's more of a process than than a
product you heard already about the
great transition initiative from from
Paul Raskin and as wanted one attempt to
do that another exercise that I was
involved with is is talked about here at
this this website we got a group of
about 40 people together and asked them
the question what would what would a the
United States look like in the year 2100
in your near perfect vision I think one
of the interesting things about these
exercises is that you get much more
consensus than you might expect from a
fairly diverse group of people if you
ask the question in that way what is
what is your vision for the future
there's quite a bit of overlap there and
we can utilize that characteristic to to
build this shared vision and then use it
to work backwards we also recently did a
study of the University of Vermont at
the academic scale what would the
university look like in in people's
preferred visions and you can take a
look at that at this website
the ESDA project ended up with several
elements I think of this shared vision
and we broke it into these five
categories of worldview natural capital
built capital human capital and social
capital and very much the things that
I've been been talking about were
elements of that vision that we have to
change our worldview to consider humans
as part of nature as part of the system
to have a more steady-state ecological
economy to have the goal be quality of
life rather than than merely consumption
that our natural capital needs to be
protected as a central life support our
built capital needs to be shifted to run
on renewable energy excetra many of the
things I think that that probably Paul
already talked about in his his vision
of the future so there is I think a an
underlying cancer
that's there that we need to really
build out flesh out and communicate and
and get more people involved in one of
the ways to do this that I think has
been quite effective is this this
process of scenario planning based on
this these four assumptions that that I
think are pretty incontrovertible that
the future is probably going to be
unlike the past and and shaped by our
choices and actions that we can't
foresee the future but we can explore
possible futures to inform present
decisions and there are many possible
futures out there and so what we really
can do is map the the possibility space
and use that as a way for people to help
make decisions about what their
preferred future is I think this can
very very effective in in this process
of creating some consensus around the
the preferred shared vision which
involves both rational analysis and and
creative thinking I think in a very
synergistic way I just put together here
a table of some of the recent scenario
exercises that have gone on it was it
was interesting to me that they they
fell out in terms of this range of
quality of life of the various scenarios
that they that they projected and and as
you probably know many of these
exercises end up with four future
scenarios usually on two different axes
I'm not sure if that's the best way to
do it but it does it does provide some
comparability even between between the
different studies one of them is most
famous ones that sort of got all of this
going was the Mont floor exercise in
South Africa where at the post apartheid
area era they created these four
scenarios which for what could happen
after the change in government and you
can see the the whoops the least
desirable one the ostrich scenario this
everybody sticks their head in the sand
and the lame duck scenario was the the
white government stays there but it
becomes a lame duck the icarus scenario
is the black government takes over and
and tries to change things too quickly
and the flight of live flamingoes was
where they they did the true
and reconciliation approached and tried
to work together in a more consistent
way and this scenario exercise I think
had a big influence on what actually
happened there they did actually take
the flight of the blooming goes scenario
seriously and try to pursue that several
others of these scenarios so you've
heard about the great transition
scenarios already in the Millennium
ecosystem assessment you've probably
heard about also used the scenario
planning exercise to talk about what
might happen to ecosystem services in
the future
I did one myself back in 1999 looking at
different possibilities for for the
future and I'll talk about a few others
that have been involved with recently
just to give you some some flavor for
how some of these things go at the
national level at the global level and
at their at the regional level for Iowa
and for the Great Barrier Reef so this
exercise I talked about tried to array
different worldviews and policies where
the conventional world view of
technological optimism that technology
will solve all of our problems versus
technological skepticism that maybe it
won't and maybe it might cause
additional problems that we haven't
foreseen versus the real state of the
world are the optimist right are the
skeptics right and if the optimists are
right we end up in the Star Trek future
if the skeptics are right we end up in
the Mad Max future and on the other hand
if we have a skeptical worldview and
policies and the optimists turn out to
be right we end up in the big government
scenario versus the eco topia scenario
I then surveyed people to ask them what
their comfort level was if they found
themselves in any of these scenarios how
how desirable would they have found it
and this is a plot of the results again
showing that sort of range of qualities
for the different scenarios the eco
topia scenario was much preferred there
were two intermediate scenarios and
there was one that was really we don't
want to go there
and I think this is often the case in
these these sort of scenario planning
is that there's a least desirable
scenario which we want to stay away from
so from a policy point of view and from
a sort of simple game theory point of
view we want to take the the position
the policies that lead to the you know
the best worst case and that would
certainly be a more skeptical point of
view in this in this analysis because if
we don't we might end up here but we
might end up in a very bad place so we
want to protect ourselves we would take
the the lower risk scenario this is a
I'll just quickly run through a couple
of other examples this is one that we
recently did in in Iowa on the future of
agriculture and in the US and this was
done as a as a problem-based course with
students from Iowa State and from the
University of Vermont and professors
from both both places and a range of
stakeholders that we visited on the
ground around around the state of Iowa
the axes that we used here were some of
the major uncertainties involved whether
energy was going to remain cheap or
become expensive and on the other axis
whether society was going to take retain
the current world view of maximizing GDP
and market the market focus versus
taking a broader GPI type of type of
focus and these are the four scenarios
that come out we also managed to produce
maps and visualizations of each of those
scenarios and so the idea is to take
this sort of information out to a much
broader public and and show them here
are the possibilities for the future of
agriculture was quite amazing that all
of the people we interviewed along the
way ranging from very conventional
farmers to organic farmers none of them
really wanted to see what was happening
continued to happen they all unanimously
almost wanted to see a return to smaller
scale farms and farm communities and and
certainly more organic production they
just were unable to to go against the
forces that were arrayed there so by
putting the vision out there and getting
some broad consensus I think we could
move move things in the right direction
another example that I've been involved
with is this one on the Great Barrier
Reef catchment and reef ecosystem
services looking at what might happen if
climate disruption is severe if the
world stays focused on on the growth
path that is on versus climate
disruption is a little bit milder if we
do get the climate situation under
control the impacts on the reef are are
both from what's happening at the global
scale affecting global sea water
temperature and an acidity but also
what's happening at the local scale
what's happening with runoff from from
the land and so that's the other axis
what happens if locally a more quality
of life focus versus an economic growth
focus stays in in play and we managed to
utilize some existing models of these
different scenarios to produce ideas
about what would happen to the coral
reef under those various scenarios under
the trashing the common scenario the
coral reef disappears under the other
other scenario some amount of coral reef
is preserved out to the year twenty one
twenty one hundred and we also managed
to Eve map those those different
scenarios again I think this would be a
very effective tool to help communicate
with the stakeholders involved what the
real possibilities are for the future
and to generate some consensus about the
preferred the preferred alternative and
then generate ways of getting there one
other example our point two is this in
New Zealand they did a visioning
exercise or a scenario planning exercise
somewhat similarly they then and the
sort of independent at Turia scenario
was the one that was obviously the the
highest quality of life they asked then
the participants after the fact where
did they think that New Zealand was in
the current period and they thought they
were generally over here they asked them
where they thought they were going and
they thought they were getting even
worse going in this direction and they
asked them where they would really want
to go and they they had this preferred
preferred scenario so this is a way of
getting at among that range of scenarios
getting building some consensus about
where
where we really want to go okay am I
almost out of time I am I I think I'll
end with with with this one which is
just a summary of what the the current
model is sometimes called the Washington
Consensus and this more sustainable and
desirable development model or future
for the system that and that the
transition that we need to make I think
is from this this middle columns vision
to the right columns vision that we need
to shift our primary goal from from more
from more economic growth from getting
bigger to to better to to to more of a
development paradigm one that focuses on
quality rather than quantity we need to
have better measures of how to do that
shifting from GDP to to GPI for example
we need to make scale or carrying
capacity a primary concern because real
biophysical limits do exist we cannot
continue to ignore them we need to make
distribution and poverty issues a
primary concern because they affect
social capital they affect quality of
life very directly there's there's
mounting evidence that that's that's a
real issue and the the conventional
model really doesn't give adequate
weight to those those considerations the
rising tide doesn't lift all boats it
turns out it only lifts all yachts so
economic efficiency and allocation is
also a primary concern in both places
but we need to bring in all of the
social and natural capital assets that
are outside the market otherwise our
conventional allocation mechanism is is
highly inefficient the externalities now
become so large that the current system
is giving us very bad information about
what the real costs of things are we
need to change our property rights ideas
to allow more emphasis on common
property resources as well as as private
and and state property resources Lynne
Elinor Ostrom wrote won the Nobel Prize
this last time for her work on common
property systems and their there are
whole regimes of common property
institutions I think we need to to
better develop in order to help us get
get there we need to recognize that
government has a central role to play
it's not to be minimized and replaced
with private and market institutions
largely because these institutions only
really deal well with private goods with
goods that are rival and excludable and
many of the things that are now
recognizably much more important to our
continued well-being are outside of that
they're not rival they're not excludable
goods they're they're public goods and
we need to take government needs to take
a central role in managing those Goods
and developing new institutions to do
that we need a to move away from
laissez-faire market capitalism to a new
set of principles for for sustainable
governance the climate skeptics have
been getting a lot of play recently and
I'm sure you can read this but you know
what what if it's a big hoax and we
create this better world for nothing so
I think our goal really is to just put
forward the better world to create that
that vision and communicate that vision
to a much broader audience I think
that's really been our challenge or the
remaining challenge I think there are
lots of people working on creating the
vision I think that vision is is
probably broadly shared but it hasn't
been really broadly shared yet we
haven't gotten it out to the general
public I don't think the general public
recognizes that there is any other way
then then the direction that we're going
in right now so how do we do that we
need to to convert not only our built
capital but also our human our social
and our natural capital assets in
various ways and we need to transform
our culture we need to chant transform
our worldviews and just to give you a
little bit of hope that maybe this may
be happening already this is from the
work of Paul ray and and sherry Anderson
on what they call the cultural creatives
they are a market research firm and
they've been surveying people since the
60s and categorizing them into these
according to their worldviews their
broad worldviews into these three
categories of cultural creatives
modernists and traditionalists and this
little tet this text here describes what
a cultural creative is but it's I think
largely the worldview that we've been
talking about what's interesting is that
the percentage of cultural creatives in
the society has been rapidly increasing
over time and that the tipping point
culturally we may be may be on the
horizon you know sooner than we think
when this group really becomes gets to a
critical mass and and can make the
transition to to the sustainable and
desirable society so and if the long
term solution is break our addiction to
this growth that all costs economic
paradigm and vision and model to fossil
fuels to overconsumption to envision
this more more sustainable and desirable
future with focusing on quality of life
it's going to require that we change
almost everything about our civilization
but it's not a sacrifice to do that it's
really a sacrifice not to do that and to
help in that in that process we're
starting a new journal slash website
called solutions that's intended to be a
very transdisciplinary hybrid academic
journal and popular magazine as a place
where we can have this ongoing
discussion about what the real solutions
might be what does what does our vision
of the future really consist of and I
think it has several unique elements I
tacuba chef's key here is the managing
editor of solution she's gonna pass
around a couple copies of the first
issue but and hopefully we'll get those
back from you and I would encourage you
all to subscribe but also contribute to
this ongoing dialogue in in various ways
I know that people in this room are
doing many things that represent pieces
of the solution what we really want is
in to to create the venue for having for
having this ongoing discussion the
internet I think is producing some some
real changes in
what is possible anyway in terms of
having this discussion we can feasibly I
think have a global dialogue about our
shared future and I think that's that's
the opportunity that we need to take if
we are to avoid the hurricane here and
turn the turn the ship even though it's
very difficult to turn towards a more
sustainable and desirable future Thanks
thank you very much Bob there's a
wonderful talk I think we have a few
minutes for for questions and and this
lecture as well as a shorter in-depth
interview will also be made available
again through Yale YouTube as well as to
the project website so yes we're trying
to disseminate make these materials as
open access as possible over here um
most of the solutions you've described
it seems like require positive
incentives or require a positive
response but people don't always respond
to that so what about negative measures
taxation and and inhibition of expensive
problems I don't have a problem with
that but I think in order to get those
sorts of policies implemented requires
that there be a positive vision on the
other side of what you're going to
achieve by by implying imposing those
and I think that's that's often the
missing element that people say no the
tax is just going to hurt me without
looking at the positive implications you
know a carbon tax is the perfect example
I mean it will help us achieve these
goals but if you don't really get people
to buy into the goals it's hard to get
them to buy into the into into the tax
okay more questions I'm Mary Ann certo
professor in our industrial ecology
group and as I think about the the basic
facts you know they're ones that we are
very sympathetic with in this school and
yet I feel like the audience out there
in our country is shrinking you know
Tony does these impressive studies about
how support for an understanding of
global warming is declining you know The
Daily News where militias are tripling
and so forth you taught you spoke about
the need to expand the audience that
this is clearly a vision that many
people are sympathetic with because you
showed many studies where you know
results were somewhat similar but there
are so many people in our country who
seem to be moving away from this kind of
a perspective and I and how do we reach
out
well I think the first step might be to
to have to return to a democracy in our
country rather than a corporate ah cracy
and I think that's that's what's been
limiting their real discussion of many
of these issues that you know that
special interests are are now
controlling you know the media as well
as you know influencing many of the
things on the ground so I don't know how
to overcome that but I think maybe Paul
Raskin mentioned that we do need a
movement of some kind you know we need
to coalesce you've probably seen Paul
Hawkens book on Blessed unrest that
there are a huge number of organizations
out there you know millions literally
that are working in this in this area
but they're very uncoordinated and so if
we could coordinate all of that activity
and get it all moving in the same
direction and I think also get past the
the media bottleneck you know by using
other media like the internet to you
know to get past the the Fox News kind
of you know distortions of what's what's
going on so I think I think there I
think there might be a tipping point
approaching though or that that's you
know that critical mass really really
gets there and I think many of the
people that are angry are angry at the
wrong people for the wrong reasons you
know and don't don't really understand
you know how how it's not really
benefiting their own self-interests or
their own or their own well-being and
you know if you propose a society with
with more jobs with more fulfilling jobs
with more leisure time with a higher
quality of life I think that's what
people really do want they just don't
see the connection between where we are
now and the policies were pursuing now
and and in that kind of future I think a
lot of the conflict comes from the
confusion of ends versus means in that
you know the the argument seems to be
between capitalists and collectivists
but really both are just tools to get to
an end and more of us agree on the ends
and agree and agree on the means right
so I think what are the ways that we can
agree on the means and avoid argument
Breann the ends it avoiding arguing
about the means well I think that's
exactly right and I think that's the
idea behind creating the shared vision
you know of of really discussing the
goals which we're not really discussing
at all we are only arguing about the the
means and certainly the the means that
are put before people are our means to a
different end they're both means to the
end of you know unlimited economic
growth so that that's the change in
vision I think that we need to to really
start discussing and and moving more
towards a you know a more shared quality
of life kind of vision neither of our
you know neither conventional capitalism
or conventional socialism I think do a
very good job of getting us to that goal
so I think we'll need new institutions
as well that will be different from the
ones that were that we have now not that
we'll throw out the market but we'll you
know we'll use the market as a servant
rather than as a master we won't share
everything equally well we'll have room
for private property but we'll also have
room for community property and for
state property and the you know in the
appropriate kind of balance so creating
those new institutions I think is is is
gonna be the challenge but I think we'll
only even get to first base with that
creation if we can create a shared
vision of what the goals are I'm dawn
Wurster an historian I'm having a little
bit of trouble figuring out what
ecological economics is at its core and
how it fits into what you just met
described as conventional capitalism
conventional socialism there's much of
what you talked about seems to me to be
very strongly a movement away from
conventional capitalism but in the
direction I suppose of socialism of some
sort but you also talk about Lovins and
Hawkins
of the world and I'm thinking
particularly their book natural
capitalism which suggests that we can
have capitalism that has an ecological
awareness everything will be fine so how
do you position yourself on that issue
and particularly the Lovins Hawkins book
well I don't think the old categories
really work anymore so I think we need
to come up with a different definition
of what we're what we're aiming for and
like I said I think the market has a
role to play in that in that spectrum of
things because it deals very well with
private goods but the problem is that
you know private goods are only a small
part of the of the real system and how
do we develop institutions that deal
with the rest but in the context so it's
not like we can shift completely to
dealing with everything as a common good
or everything as a private good but
there's a balance in between so it's a
you know it's a little of both and I've
been actually looking for you know a
word for that for a while you know so
what is what is this sustainable quality
of life economy one word that I've come
up with is a Swedish word legume which
means that there's enough to go around
and and it's shared you know relatively
equally but it's not you know sort of a
minimalist kind of thing so it really
embodies several of the elements
ecological economics really thinks about
sustainable scale you know so you can't
be too big to impact your life support
system fairer distribution how do you
how do you share things equitably or
fairly not necessarily equally and an
efficient allocation how do you make
sure you use things efficiently so
that's that's kind of the essence of
ecological economics and it's not really
well embodied in any of our existing
paradigms but needs to we need to create
something I think something new for the
third millennium
something that's going to also last and
with that I think Bob will be here for
at least a few more minutes to talk
informally if you'd like so if you'll
please join me in thanking